hello everyone today I'm going to talk
about how I learned to CSS
I'm also paranoid about my presentation
malfunctioning half way so if you okay
if you want to scan the QR code and load
the slides on your mobile device feel
free to do so now I've talked to a lot
of people about CSS and a number of them
have told me that they they don't like
CSS that CSS is hard to wrap their head
around so I'm gonna share with you how I
wrap my head around CSS now the purpose
of CSS is to make stuff on the web look
good I mean you can't have cascading
style sheets without spell right but I
also see CSS as a means of creative
expression I mean some people like to
write some people paint some people make
music I like to CSS now as with any
creative endeavor we need some
inspiration well the CSS specification
if you print it out I don't know maybe
it's this thick so there's a lot of
stuff in there for us to explore and
play with many people myself included
write articles about CSS some of us even
write books so read those because they
usually come with code examples that you
can fork off and play around with
yourself podcasts now I'm sure a lot of
you commute in some way or another
I personally commute by bicycle so
there's not a lot of things I can do
with my hands or my eyes technically
this applies if you're driving as well
but your ears are free and there are a
lot of good web development podcasts out
there that discuss the latest trends
techniques new stuff which is perfect
for finding out about new stuff and also
discovering old stuff that you never
knew existed and if you're anything like
me you might find confidence a tad
expensive I mean maybe I'm up here
because I was too cheap to pay for a
ticket joking kind of and a lot of the
conference's including this one actually
put up videos of the talks online after
the fact so if you want to skip over the
face to face interaction with
like-minded people or the prospect of
meeting your
pelipper idols then go ahead just watch
the free videos online there's really a
ton of good content there and then just
start building stuff now ooh no crap
oona credits once it is on her excellent
podcast PS you must subscribe to it
people go to conferences to get inspired
and learn about things that exist or
maybe an overview of how to use it but
then they really learn that thing that
technology when they go home and
practice it themselves so that's what I
hope that I can I can do today that at
the end of the day at the end of all
these excellent talks that you too will
be inspired to go home and CSS something
yourself but building stuff is not
enough you really ought to share what
you've built with the world because well
you can do this in two ways you can
either write write about it or you can
talk about it because when you do that
you're forced to explain stuff and this
really makes you learn about what
exactly what's going on so who's this
person standing in front of you talking
about CSS I mean I should introduce me a
bit so my first name is swaging
I'm a self-taught designer and developer
I work at a company called deep that and
I write blog posts from time to time so
I put some stuff recently and Here I am
sharing it with all of you because I
only have 15 minutes I'm just gonna
cover some key points only first up is
what I call over-the-top video buttons
so I watched a video of ether and more
cots excellent talk at an event part
earlier this year linked in this light
and I was particularly enamored with his
demo demonstrating progressively
enhanced radio buttons now one thing
about conference talks is unless the
speaker is live coding the code snippets
that we show you are just a tiny snippet
of the key functionality I learned that
the hard way because I was like oh
there's not a lot of code here I could
probably build this in half an hour
wrong took me at least I don't know
three days and maybe more but these are
cool takeaways I got from trying to
build this demo students which so here's
the demo so it's essentially just radio
buttons but there's some animation going
on there's some sliding and some zooming
you can clear your selection and
everything just slides back this is all
powered by CSS
javascript involved in this demo is to
add and remove classes so then there's
also this slight pause the animation
thing Sarah actually touched on
animations earlier so the crux of this
demo is a technique called the check box
hack so I'm sure all of us have built
HTML forms before and we should know
that form control elements like inputs
should have an Associated label element
so you can do this in two ways you can
either have the label contain the input
or you can use the for attribute on the
label which points to the ID of the
input element I actually found out
recently that the second method is
recommended because some assistive
technologies don't work properly with
the wrapping method so now when you
click the label it's as if you clicked
and checked the radio button and because
you can use images as part of the label
not only text you can actually get
really fancy with the label so then when
a radio button or checkbox is checked we
have a check pseudo class that we can
play with so together with some
combinators either sibling selectors or
child selectors depending on how you
wrote your HTML we can have some fun
with the state change so we can have
some animation as Sarah mentioned
earlier the way browsers work now there
are only two things that can be animated
cheaply transforms and opacity and both
of which I use in this demo so that
sliding thing that you saw earlier that
was translate X and I used it with some
end child selectors so my four options
were laid out with flexbox actually in a
single row so they're only going to move
along the x-axis and the selected option
always ends up in the second position so
we can set up some positioning rules
using entrant selectors so if the first
option is checked it will always move
one position to the right so I can use
translate X 100% to do that and for the
third and fourth they're always going to
move one or two positions respectively
to the left so we'll use a negative
percentage for the translate X and then
there's the zooming bit so basically
what I have more two disks that were
stacked on top of each other along the
z-axis so if you peek into my source
code you'll see some Z index rules
thrown in there
and the use of the knot selector here is
helpful because what happens is that the
stuff that you want to display when
checked is hidden from view at first and
I did this by setting the opacity to
zero and scaling it down to nothing so
when you check one option you want the
other three to disappear and the istrict
class is only added to the selector
option while the other three without end
up getting these height from view
properties because they are not is
checked so the classes that are prefixed
with is are added and removed by
JavaScript and those were those are the
only things that the JavaScript is doing
in this demo and then transitions so
transitions or what pull this whole demo
together because without them your my
options will just jump into place
there's none none of that smooth you
know sliding and zooming and I use
transitions quite often I think it's
quite commonly used and but one thing
that I actually never used before this
demo is the transition delay property
and you use it to specify the amount of
time the browser waits from the time you
request the animation to when the
animation actually starts so it turns
out that very slight pause it's a 0.1
second pause actually does make a
difference so I have this demo up on
quote pen and you can fork it and mess
around with the timing just to see the
effect right so I watched another talk
now this talk was by Harry Roberts on
structuring your CSS it was great there
was some way involved the sandwich not
the trains but his point was your CSS
classes shouldn't be monolithic because
that's actually creating a single point
of failure so you handle layout
separately from component Styles and
have specialized JavaScript books so if
you change the visual style of a
component by maybe changing classes
you're not going to break any
functionality so that's the reason why I
have this disparate classes here and
someone pointed out to me that I should
really make my demo keyboard accessible
well I'm gonna preface that I'm not very
good at accessibility right now so I'm
still learning from people like Chris
about how to do this well unfortunately
I couldn't come up with a solution for
making the checkbox heck
keyboard accessible so if any of you do
please come and talk to me about it
but the next best idea I had was to have
a toggle so you can turn the app you can
turn the animation off you can just fall
back to a normal so this is just your
basic normal radio buttons and for those
of you who have actually never tried
navigating a forum with keyboard know
that you use tap to jump between
elements you use the arrow keys to
navigate between options and if it's a
checkbox you use space key to select and
unselect your options so the source code
and the quote pen link if you're
interested right so one more demo this
one is what I call a CSS album art so I
came across this blog post by a designer
come musician he's called Scott Hanson
and he was outlining his design process
for album covers and I noticed that in
his design for some of his covers was
pretty minimalist you know just shapes
shapes that can be created only using
CSS so here's the demo and as you can
see the the covers are really simply
just shapes so these are all created
using just ESS there's no images
involved and for some reason I thought
that it'd be cool to try doing this in
just with just one single diff so I
definitely needed some help with from
pseudo elements so when you have the you
can use the before and the after pseudo
elements so now I have like a total of
three elements to play with the thing
about pseudo elements is that you it
must have the content property in order
for it to work and the content cannot be
blank you have to have at least empty
codes so zero elements are considered
inserted content so what what happens is
that sorry what happens is that it's not
visible in the pages source so ideally
you don't want to have any critical
content that is inserted into your your
website in this way but for decorative
things like what I'm doing right now I
think it's it's it's still fine so here
we go
shapes with CSS so it's gonna start off
with something
simple this be a circle the
border-radius is obviously the key
property here but one thing is I also
wanted to make my demo responsive so
none of that fixed with stuff no no
we're gonna use viewport units for this
so what viewport units are is these are
units that are relative to the height
and width of your viewport and the V min
unit that I'm using here actually is
based on your current viewport width or
height depending on whichever is smaller
so next rape actually I want to talk
about is a triangle so you can create
triangles with CSS using the border
property so unlike if unlike me you had
better things to do with your life
you've probably never done this before
but say create a div of any size you
choose 200 pixels square for example and
then you apply a different color thick
border to each of the four sides so so
maybe about 30 pixels you'll see that
the edges of the border actually meet
diagonally so now if your div does not
have a height or a width then you're
left with 4 triangles and so you see you
can have triangles of different
directions and with that we can create
different CSS triangles so for this case
it's a right facing triangle so all you
have to do is to make the adjacent
borders transparent so for this one my
top and border are transparent while the
desired color is applied to the border
left you can even change the width of
the border to change the shape of your
triangle so the next shape is a
trapezium
I consider this a cop-out shape because
it's actually just a regular diff with
it it just snipped off with CSS clip
path CSS clip path uses the same polygon
syntax as SVG's and as CSS shapes with
each point being a coordinate relative
to the width and the height of the diff
unfortunately clip path is not supported
in any of the Microsoft browsers but
it's currently under consideration in
the masking module so I think you can
probably vote for this
we're okay this is a fun one so on some
of the covers I'm gonna switch back you
can see a series of dots at the site so
not this one
so those those series of dots those were
actually done using the what I call the
box shadow trick so I came across this
fantastic site showcasing really
interesting single day of CSS creations
and when I first saw it I was like
that's not possible that how do you own
or do you actually do that with one div
turns out a lot of bit involved this
particular trick so you know how I said
that the before and after a pseudo
element gave you two more elements to
play with box shadow actually gives you
I don't know unlimited more someone
please correct me on this but the the
limit the limitation here is that it can
only be one shape because I mean it's
the shadow of something but the syntax
is as follows and what you can do is you
can use the offsets which are the first
two values for positioning and the blur
radius for sizing so for the album's
there are 11 dots so it looks like that
11.11 box shadows so that's that okay
this one is purely grata to us because
my original code pen demo just had
everything aligned right smack down the
middle using flexbox but then I came
across an article by none other than
Sarah Dresner talking about CSS scroll
snapped I like why not I just you can
just throw this in it seems like a
perfect East case for this so CSS scroll
snap was actually introduced in for
scroll positions so users don't land at
awkward scroll positions that leave a
page partially on screen when panning
okay fine it's scroll jacking but I can
understand the reason for this use case
and it actually works kind of kind of
well with the keyboard but the
specification is unstable yet and it
only works on Firefox and surprisingly
Microsoft edge but then it doesn't
support clip path this is you know like
but the key property here for CSS
scrolls net is the scroll snap type on
the container and the scroll snap
coordinate on the inner element so this
is the kind of thing that is really
makes a lot of sense if you play around
with the code yourself so I've also have
a code pen demo one thing about this is
that if you look at the existing
polyfills that are around online I found
two but they both only support the older
syntax so they don't work very well
CSS scroll snap only works natively on
as I said Firefox and itch so the source
code and the code pen link is here one
thing to note about trying out the
latest and greatest is to always check
with can I use com just to see how
browser support is but that being said
there's never been a better time to then
now to live on the cutting edge because
evergreen browsers are a thing now and
we don't have to wait six months for a
new feature
Safari so here's all the related reading
in more or less the order that I talked
about them really good stuff suggest
that you go through this when you have
time and that's it for me
you